life is funny isn't it sometimes you
don't know what to believe when
something strange happens people start
searching for answers and when they
don't find the answers that they like
they just start making things up
that's how we end up with conspiracy
theories and i'm sure you've heard
plenty of them bigfoot
who i kind of believe in but need to see
better quality video
did the moon landing really happen in
1969
or was it faked
that's crazy
loch ness monster
i yelled i said what do you want from us
monster and the monster bent down
instead
i need about 350.
that body of water too small
and don't even get me started on the
martians
i'm open to believing in them i just
want to see some proof
besides james carville of course
we are just looking for the truth
much as you try to bury it the truth is
out there
conspiracy theories can be fun they can
be crazy but sometimes they can be true
many times conspiracy theories are just
things the media might lose a lot of
money over
what starts as a crazy idea actually
isn't that crazy at all
like what's going on with joe biden and
the cartels
i'm not saying joe biden's actively
colluding with the cartels although
there's more evidence of this than there
was of trump colluding with russia
but just look at his policies and who
benefits
and as always follow the money
because it certainly seems like both the
cartels and the democratic party are
mutually benefiting from what's
unfolding along the border and
so were the chinese
since joe biden took over nearly 2
million migrants had been caught
crossing into the country more than half
have stayed and hundreds of thousands
more we just missed
this was by design
buy and invited them during the campaign
i would in fact make sure that there is
we immediately surge to the border all
those people are seeking asylum they
deserve to be heard
and that was only the start biden just
deconstructed trump's border policies
because of pride little vanity and fear
mostly
fear that the far left would revolt
against them
who's actually benefiting from these
open border policies well that would be
the cartels
drug and human trafficking are fattening
the bank accounts of mexico's most
dangerous syndicates last year kansas
senator roger marshall estimated that
cartels are charging central american
families anywhere between three and nine
grand to get people into the u.s
with over two million people crossing
last year at a rate of about nine g's a
person you can see why the cartels have
gotten into the business of human
smuggling
and with agents tied up playing
babysitter or bus driver or whatever
drugs are just flooding in at a nasty
clip
bringing in another 19 to 20 billion
billion for the cartels cocaine heroin
and fentanyl killed over a hundred
thousand americans last year
the chinese ship the synthetics to the
mexican ports the cartels drive the
goods inland and then cook it into
fentanyl at their labs and then they
move it north across our border
it hits the streets puts americans to
sleep and the profits are sent back
south then they get washed
a congressional committee reported that
chinese brokers are laundering mexican
drug money through china's financial
system
why are we letting this happen
biden was caught cold flying single
adult male migrants into new york in the
dead of
night you don't want to be somewhere
where
the spotlight is yeah
down low as possible a lot of this is
just
no i get it i just like stuff that we
don't
tell people because what we don't want
to do is attract attention we don't want
the media yeah like we don't even know
where we're going when they tell us
i have children they act sneaky when
they know they're up to no good
i get the whole
secrecy and all this [ __ ] but this is
even about my
yeah you know what i mean
[Music]
you know what i mean
and why
you know why you know what yeah i know
but why
yeah
no but what's what's the big secret
everybody knows what's happening
why is biden betraying us
these migrants can vote in new york city
elections they want citizens from other
countries voting in american elections
eight hundred thousand new voters here
they also pad the census for democrats
in fact they can go to college on my
dime
so we rack up college debt but biden
traffic's dreamers who get tuition
breaks
not only that a migrant can hold up a
liquor store in manhattan with a handgun
and he's only charged with a misdemeanor
and he can't get deported because we're
in a sanctuary city
joe biden's running a human smuggling
operation
the cartels hand them to biden at the
border and then biden puts them in buses
and planes and then just sprinkles them
all over the country
it's happening right in front of our own
eyes
illegals come in and help big business
keep wages down
just what the donors want
guess they got what they paid for
migrants take cash so you can dodge
taxes too
and then they wire the money back south
so other families can pay cartel coyotes
and boom another caravan it's another
batch of democrat voters
isn't this foreign interference in our
elections
biden soft on china and the cartels
while his family make money there
but americans get hurt but donors make a
profit
maybe this is why the democrats don't
care about border security or maybe
this is just one big conspiracy theory
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else